this somber setting is home to the Boyar
car sanatorium in the Ukrainian capital
Kiev more than a hundred and fifty
tuberculosis patients are undergoing
treatment here many have a multi
drug-resistant form of the disease
this means the drugs used to combat the
pathogen have little or no effect 68
year-old fazil who'd previously enjoyed
good health only learned of his
condition by chance when I had a routine
check-up at work they saw something on
the x-ray I didn't even have any
symptoms I felt fine Pavlo who's in his
late 20s would prefer to be at home with
his wife and daughter
unlike fazil he's pretty sure he knows
how he contracted the disease I got the
multi-resistant strain of tuberculosis
from my buddy after he was released from
prison the facility has no isolation
wards and no proper ventilation this
makes it especially hard to fight
multi-resistant TB but physician
Vladimir's shikaka points to an even
bigger problem
quitting the treatment is still the
easiest way to develop multi strain
resistant tuberculosis the biggest
problem with this is that the treatment
takes a really long time to complete 20
months it's hard to stay with it even
highly motivated people find it hard to
take large amounts of medication every
day for 20 months the pathogen thrives
in crowded places especially where it's
cold and there's a little sunlight it
spreads easily through sneezing coughing
and even just regular conversation
it's easy to identify the signature red
pattern under a microscope but
distinguishing the regular kind from the
multi resistance strain is expensive and
lengthy it takes up to two months to get
a diagnosis that means people with the
multi resistant strain can unknowingly
continue to infect others the lab at the
sanatorium is able to determine if a
strain is resistant to the antibiotic
rifampicin it's one of the most
effective anti tuberculosis drugs on the
market the computer-controlled tests can
produce results within a few hours but
in order to know if it's resistant to
other drugs they have to take bacterial
cultures that takes several weeks using
genetic testing it's possible to decode
the pathogens genome in a matter of days
but that's expensive and to date there
are only four devices in all of Ukraine
that can do this the lab here is still
waiting to get one
questions remain as to why this
multi-resistant strain is so prevalent
in Ukraine
besides the problem with people not
sticking to the full course of treatment
experts point to the country's
overstretched health care system
patients like these here in foyer car
are too often housed in cramped quarters
this has drawn widespread criticism
people out there we still have people
sharing rooms but the patient's aren't
isolated and have too much contact with
each other in this environment you can
imagine how easy it is for patients to
infect each other with resistant strains
but we're still optimistic that we're
getting new technology treatment methods
and resources
after years of seeing infections rise
the number of cases in Ukraine dropped
for the first time in 2016 for doctors
and patients here their bottom line in
the fight against multi-resistant TB
faster Diagnostics and better long-term
care for patients
you